what i would like to do in this video is
get some practice estimating the product
of multi-digit numbers and there's just
no better way of getting practice than
just trying it ourselves and so right
over here it says estimate 29 times 3198
why don't you pause this video and try
to estimate this and of course you can
do this by multiplying this out on paper
or using a calculator but this is a
useful skill try to do it in your head
see if you can estimate what this is
going to be
well before even looking at these
answers i would say this is going to be
approximately equal to
let's see 29 is awfully close to 30 and
then i could multiply that times i could
either multiply that times 3200 which is
awfully close to 3198
or if i want an even more rough
approximation i could say that's roughly
equal to 30 times 3
000. so if i did 30 times 3000 3 times 3
is equal to
9 and then i have one two three four
zeros one two three four zeros and
actually my approximation it turns out
is here right over here 90 000. now if i
wanted a slightly better approximation i
could have said this is approximately
equal to 30 times
3200 and this you could also do in your
head you could say well what is 3 times
32 well that is going to be 96 and then
you have one two three zeros one two
three zero so this would be a slightly
better approximation and if this is what
you got the closest answer here is still
going to be equal to 90 000.
let's do another example
so here we are asked to estimate 137
times 18. so pause this video again and
see if you can come up with an estimate
try to do it in your head
well there's once again many ways of
trying to tackle it the way i would
tackle it i would say well that's pretty
close to 140 times 20
and then this would be equal to 14 times
2 is 28 and then we have two zeros here
so that would be roughly 2800 but when i
look over here there is no 2800
and so
maybe the closest one right over here is
2 000 so that would be my that could be
an approximation another way it looks
actually the way that they did it is
they even did a coarser approximation
they rounded this to the nearest hundred
and so they said this is approximately
equal to 100 times and they rounded this
to the nearest 10 100 times 20 which is
even easier to do in your head which is
equal to 2000 which is this choice that
they got right over here